so Olga the neighbor the neighborhood
we're going to does not look like that
right
yeah it doesn't look like that the worst
thing the worst neighborhood in is right
because it can't all look this good it's
impossible all I've seen it our nice
streets cleanliness order do you know
these these doors their nuclear doors
yeah that's why I stopped
Stalin built this in all of the metros
and so you can see the slides up there
and it would come across there's another
one over there
so midday it's quiet like this nobody's
here
[Music]
soon
cool station huh
nice bus
try to figure it out how do you explain
Chocolate Factory
guess what it says what I want
you sure this is the right neighborhood
this region
how do you mean explain right
yeah it's not it doesn't look that bad
yet it's more dangerous because we're
here so we're getting closer to the
neighborhood here what I just don't see
what's so bad about this yet look at
this this concrete is perfect this
asphalt is perfect there's no trash
what's bad about this look at this road
it looks like bull adidas track see the
bad neighborhood starts now
[Music]
even given not like some regions of
Russia or Ukraine Here I am oh say this
is the place you go looking for dates
yeah your dream man yeah you think after
this video they're all gonna come over
to Belarus with me further man in this
neighborhood guys if you haven't noticed
yet it's it's just been pissing rain
today doing our best to find you the bad
neighborhood in Minsk and I'm not
convinced I'm not convinced you're
finding me anything Olga
okay I think I need to take you to the
south side of Chicago seriously or
south-central Los Angeles dangers
compared to this yes definitely
guns homicides scary people drunk people
cracked out people yeah you're
disappointing me
I wanted to I wanted to see some grit in
Belarus because all I've seen I just
thought it is unfair showing the
downtown with Polish streets and nice
wide boulevards said let's see the other
side of Minsk you got me walking in the
rain on this perfect pavement this bar
it's a bar
I mean mints style dive bar
look at this it's perfect
where we have them see us
Minsky across Korea possibly yes near
the near post near very own home in ski
show her show
Plus croutha mr. George Easton she oh no
mom
boss it's the rain okay spasiba
just liver she altitude involution by
the way she said to you Cal Alaska it
means please in Belarus our language
sweet so they speak Belarusian out here
in the outskirts of the city
you like dangerous guys you like wild
guys
you're looking for trouble
Adventure adventure but look at it as
far as a market goes look at
unbelievable unbelievable how nice it is
you ready this is the way in you're
saying wait today the roots of paradise
so you're saying this is this is the way
into the bad neighborhoods with knives
come on you're being you're being are
you being too politically correct
there's got to be some it's that
peaceful really so ok no guns people
don't have guns that's obvious you can
buy guns but knives people have not
they're stabbings here they're killings
kitchen knives look at this let's go
inside here let's check this out but
even in the terrible neighborhood so you
say there's no trash really that's weird
this camera sucks in low light it sucks
in the light but let's just get out of
that rain look even this is nice
[Music]
one you know most of these hallways are
pretty dirty and ugly usually like in
Ukraine definitely yes you're not making
many Ukrainian friends today I love
Ukraine
you know I lived there right it is
there's a lot of soul in Ukraine okay
mission failed we're gonna find the hard
edge of Minsk because you know Minsk is
an extreme place you know this extreme
extreme everything's extreme it's like
the Kentucky Fried Chicken here has this
massive Soviet realism display above it
that makes you feel like charging off to
war but then you just want to get some
ice cream with chicken okay look at this
this this playground in the rough what
is the name of this neighborhood by the
way yes sir this Kurtis after Curtis
Ashima there's some trash first yeah
first wrapper finally you found some
trace this is gonna seem like a
propaganda video I swear to God I'm
doing my best to find
a shitty part of town yeah anyway we've
still got small chance to find something
near the market
let's try okay yeah I mean but every
city is a city of 2 million people
sweet let's get out of this rain
the city of 2 million people
yeah the average salary is what our
president says with it's $500 bus all
these people know that it's not so the
average salary is not even $500
something doesn't add up to me
so people are living pretty low a lot of
people living with not much money right
because people here they know how to
save money they know how to count how
much money for what they need who
doesn't know they just drink alcohol
they don't think about anything good so
they just live their paradise like in
their mind okay so do we have another
place to go to or is this it let's go
look for it it's a nice-looking shop
doesn't look that yeah you're joking no
seriously no really you're joking
I think you are for me it's bad it's
freezing seriously I like the uniforms
that little hats they're wearing what is
that what's going on they're all all
shops so this shot yet a last-place had
red hats this one has blue hats
this is what the market looks like in
the can't even say it but let's call it
the bad side of Minsk
[Music]
I'm your worst tourist usually they want
to go to nice places I want to go to bad
places okay that's the Minsk market nice
place okay let's try one more place yeah
one more stop along this journey through
the rain deep into the jungle
okay here's so what do you love about
what do you love about Belarus tell me
something you love you can you travel a
lot
[Applause]
[Music]
so I feel with all these wide parks and
big parks and wide boulevards there's
just a lot I don't know it my head feels
a little more peaceful if that makes any
sense
I can have a little more space of my
thoughts there's everything spread out
but not in like a suburb not like in a
Phoenix suburbian Phoenix Arizona you
know this place Phoenix or Los Angeles
these are big sprawled out suburban
cities but this is actually enjoyable to
walk around maybe not this neighborhood
so much but with all the parks and all
the cool streets and all the monuments
it's nice to walk around even though
you'd want a car here the mass of Soviet
architecture of the monuments I love
that stuff that I find a super
interesting the constructivism the
Brutalism all the you know the Lenin
statues the hammer and sickle it's super
interesting okay what sucks about Minsk
[Music]
people are generally depressed okay this
way and then over
okay the crazy thing is you say the
level of life yeah isn't high okay but
if you go to say Italy this is a Western
so-called wealthy country and you go to
Rome
Rome is way more beat up than this place
you know what I mean
wow that's cool look at this I just is
what I love about Minsk
these long walkways but Rome is way more
beat up it's dirtier the infrastructures
more beat up they make more money but
actually it's so expensive that I don't
it might even be better here I don't
know dope Nick being redneck blue faces
is like is that gang turf or is it kid
stuff um I think it's kid stuff actually
I suppose yeah okay
there we go some signs of danger perhaps
yeah this is what the most dangerous
neighborhood does for art and it hasn't
been spray-painted or knocked down we
dissect it a lot there's a building is
that a dangerous building you think so
actually building looking nice but you
never know who lives inside especially
in this region such people live in more
concentrated more than in other regions
some people go in prison some people
already back in this region such people
most opposed and in all means more
criminals here than anywhere yeah did
you know around like ten years ago in
this region you could meet really ten
years ago there were guns I knew it
wasn't dangerous but as there's always a
real bad part to any big city usually
there is and I'm not seeing it so guys
maybe a little bit of a letdown maybe
not but the story is Minsk is not a
dangerous city and we got totally wet
and walks quite a ways to try to find a
different truth for you but this is what
it is anything else to say okay so I
just want to say welcome to me you can't
even even stay in chorus throw them
tell them you can even stay in for
assault Sina and you feel good weather
here
arranging Department will be much
cheaper so oh by the way let's just look
at the nice stonework and curbs in the
worst neighborhoods and Minsk
unbelievable
I think there might be more to this
story but maybe not maybe that's it ok
Kuta open 6 p.m. very cool experience
so guys also I got a route like a edited
video of Minsk with music shows all the
beautiful sides sites and it's actually
not raining the whole time so it looks
beautiful blue skies somewhere at the
end of this video
you